okay folks a little bit of a drive
background I know I'm actually traveling
on business right now and thanks to the
miracle that is netflix streaming i have
finally watched The Hunger Games and I
may be late to this party but I really
feel like I need to talk to about it
while it's still fresh in my head I put
off watching this thing for a very long
time there are two reasons the first one
it's based of a book series and the age
range of the audience for that series is
of an age that makes me really cautious
it's the same demographic that made
Twilight huge so that was thing one
thing two can be summed up in just a
couple of words battle royale I am an
enormous fan of the film battle royale
and frankly it's the same basic plot
bunch of teenagers have to kill each
other until there's only one left I was
very convinced that I would not be able
to set those similarities aside and set
my love of battle where else I'd be able
to appreciate this film for what it was
I decided you know I needed to just give
it a shot and I did tonight you know
what I'm glad I did just addressing the
battle royale thing very quickly yes the
very basic premise is effectively the
same but the execution completely
different for so many reasons battle
royale is down to simple effective
brutality and that is what makes it as
such a brilliant film this is something
else altogether this is a bit more
nuanced this has a lot more kind of
going on behind the scenes in terms of
the nuts and bolts of why everything's
happening battle royale wasn't concerned
about the whys it was concerned about
showing you this carnage this movie
isn't about that and it's that different
intent in the execution that makes it a
completely different film despite its
similarities in prep and premise so what
works in this thing honestly the world
the world is really fascinating and the
whole thing with the districts and the
level that technology is that and even
the stuff that in the trailer looked
ridiculous like the lady gaga costumes
that everyone in the capital wears it
works in a school that helps build this
really big really interesting world the
performances are also spot on I already
knew Jennifer Lawrence
was a good actress but she's got just
sheer presence and incredible subtle tea
here she conveys an awful lot by doing
an awful little and it's that's a really
hard thing to pull off and she nails
that so well and she's supported by a
great cast as well many whom are capable
of doing that same thing Woody Harrelson
great example Donald Sutherland does
very little but conveys so much you've
got some more over-the-top performances
as well but they're great to wes Bentley
gives a good performance for the first
time since American Beauty Stanley Tucci
is always great in everything it doesn't
matter if the movie sucked or not he's
always great Elizabeth Banks she really
surprised me just because her character
is so aggressively shallow it's really
kind of amazing just across the board
incredibly well cast very well performed
and I actually want to single out the
sound design and the music on this thing
I like good sound work but I'm not an
audio file but the sound design on this
thing is incredible and so much is
conveyed with those sounds some of the
hits that are delivered in the fight
they're brutal and they're brutal
because of the sound design and other
things as well the sound when katniss
draws that bone those metal arrows
scrape against the bow that is a
signature sound and the music to it
often plays against what you expect from
many of the scenes that it's used in but
that all plays very well into the
atmosphere of the film as much as this
film surprise me on a lot of levels now
I'm definitely glad i saw it it's not
perfect remember that fantastic world I
talked about well it's so good that when
the actual hunger games themselves start
it feels a little bit like a step back
because the Hunger Games the competition
where these all these teenagers have to
fight it out to the death takes place in
the woods and the woods could be
anywhere in any timeframe and you lose
all the flavor uniqueness of the world
that we've just been with for the first
hour thankfully we still get little
touches up because it flashes back and
we see woody harrelson still negotiating
for things for his team and you see the
different districts you know viewing the
games as they were going so we touch
back in that world but the actual hunger
games themselves probably the least
interesting part of the movie it's not
bad ness
but another thing that the games
themselves have working against it is
the camera work there's a lot of very
unnecessary shaky cam in this and
sometimes it works when it's a more
low-key up so that you just get that
handheld feel the cameras just bobbing a
little bit it so it makes it feel a
little more intimate and that's fine but
as soon as the action scene starts the
camera starts doing this and it makes
the action scenes difficult to follow
the main reason I'm able to follow the
action scenes at all is because of that
brilliant sound design I mentioned but
the camera work itself is distracting
it's not as offensive as these things
can be i've seen some movies that are so
bad with the shaky cam I just I can't
even watch them is this isn't that bad
but it's not good and I wish they hadn't
done it I suspect part of the reason
they do it is to be able to secure a
pg-13 rating because if these fights
were filmed any more clearly this thing
would probably have to be rated R which
would alienate the main demographic you
know the people actually read the books
so it may have been as much a logistical
decision as a stylistic one but it just
still annoys me and there are a couple
of story aspects that don't play as well
as they probably should have and I think
they're probably really only there
because they were such an important part
of the book there's a character I'm not
even gonna name this character because I
think I might end up getting getting too
much indisposed with that but there's a
character who it seems very obvious from
the way this character is used that they
are very big in the book and very
important in the book and they're
important in certain aspects in this but
they don't appear a lot so when this
character eventually gets paid off the
film it kind of banks too much on that
payoff and it doesn't feel earned I'm
sure it probably works very well in the
book the problem when the movie is it
was already two hours and 20 minutes
long and for this payoff to of work
right that you probably would have
needed at least in another 15 minutes
with this character specifically for the
payoff to work as well as they're trying
to make it there's some other nitpicky
things although the CGI didn't work for
me also the fire looked really fake and
I mean that both in terms of the fake
fire that's on the close of the
characters as well as the real fire that
goes on in the forest at one point
there's some creatures at the end they
they
wonky thankfully they're kept in
darkness that helps a little bit but for
something that was hype this much and
had the budget that I'm sure this thing
had I would I was expecting a little bit
more solid special effects work but you
know these are minor quibbles and this
thing just it really surprised the heck
out of me and now I gotta go and see the
next one before the third one comes out
so let me ask you this what's the movie
that had been hiked up for you and you
were sure I'm not really gonna enjoy
this you went to see it and it turned
out to be way better than you thought it
was going to be give me an example let's
share let's talk about it until next
time this council is adjourned